hello again after this morning my staff
has prepared sort of the conclusions of
the panels and I'm now bedded to mine
should I should I read them out to you
but I will have to read them myself
first and I I'm warming to the idea of
cloning after a day like today you know
it's a would be good idea to be able to
be in two different places at the same
time if it's okay with you in closing I
would rather give you some of the
thoughts I have collected hearing people
tell me about today and also with other
meetings I have had what we need be if
if we agree that perhaps our biggest
challenges is to get the governance of
all of this right because we seem to
agree on the end goal we want to achieve
we also seem to agree globally on the
measures in the different sectors that
will be necessary to get us there
then the what is no longer the real
issue it's the how that is the real
issue and if we agree that the how is
the real issue then I believe that the
way we organize ourselves is going to be
of eminent importance and if if you are
part of that organization through the
climate pact and other methods I am sure
with all the other stakeholders we can
come up with the optimal answers perfect
answers don't exist but optimal answers
perhaps we can achieve in this context I
honestly believe that climate law has a
crucial role to play and I got it back
several times you don't want a Christmas
tree
well nor do we and by the way you know
if you want to be enlighted a Christmas
tree is not the best option either in
terms of energy consumption nor and
of illumination so we need to have
something that's focused LED lights in
lighting us but the core issue is this
can the climate law contribute to giving
us enough guidance enough security to
follow this path and at the same time
offer us enough flexibility to take
different brief occasions or roads when
external factors will show that perhaps
we've made the wrong choice so we should
put more emphasis here this development
takes care of itself this development
needs more support the crucial
contribution the climate law can make is
to offer long term predictability and
security that parties who will have to
decide whether we achieve this commit to
something and are willing to say I
commit to this and if I deviate I'm
willing to be corrected I think this is
one of the most important things
especially investors need because the
investors I've met so far whether it's
in my office potential investors I've
met so far whether it's much in my
office from the financial sector from
venture capital sector from
institutional investor sector in my
office or in Davos or elsewhere all of
them say give us good projects give us
an idea it's not not the fact that they
don't have money they just don't want to
take more risk than is sellable to their
constituents which is logical and I
honestly believe that the climate law
can give that extra bit of security that
some investors need to make this jump
into the future and and and this jump
into the future is a challenge to all of
us you know if I talk to leaders of
European industry they know they need to
go they know they know what to do but
they struggle with how to do it they
know the transition needs to happen they
know that the end goal will be positive
for
but the transition itself is it is a
challenge and there I believe the
climate law can be of help and if we can
then bring together all the stakeholders
and also make it possible for European
industry to get access to credits that
are affordable and that are sustainable
then I believe this transition will go
ahead and and let me end on this on this
notion which I'm discovering actually on
them on a daily basis since we are in
such a deep transformational process
it's part of human experience that some
things will not work out the way we plan
them there will be more difficult it
will be slower and sometimes they will
not succeed other things will go much
faster than anybody had anticipated we
seed for instance now in sustainable
energy generation etc but in combination
with the Green Deal as a roadmap and
extra security provided by things such
as the climate law this will put us on
the right track to achieve climate
neutrality by 2050 and to achieve a
substantial reduction of emissions by
2030 which I hope will be in line with
what the expectations are of the
European Parliament and if properly
assessed for impact can also be
supported by the European Commission
thank you so much for being here today
I will not prolong your agony any longer
by keeping keeping on speaking I count
on your contribution I count on your
solidarity you can count on mine my team
led by the example is at your disposal
if there are things you see that aren't
going well it's nice if you tell us that
things are going well but it's better
you tell us that things are where things
are not going well so that perhaps we
can have an opportunity to fix it this
will continue to be a cooperative factor
we are not just refocusing our economy
shifting it away from carbon to a carbon
neutral we
also reinventing governance we are
reinventing governance because it will
be it will be inclusive governance if it
is to succeed and for that we need all
of you thank you very much
[Applause]